para revisar cómo hemos llegado a este
vídeo en 1865 méndez compartido por
primera vez sus leyes de la herencia él
observó que existen factores
hereditarios que se transmiten de padres
a hijos de acuerdo con ciertas reglas y
él descubrió las leyes de la herencia
las cuales son la primera segunda y
tercera ley de méndez pero como hemos
dicho varias veces el trabajo de méndez
al ser compartido no fue tomado en serio
al inicio de hecho mucha gente no le
prestaba atención y no fue sino hasta el
año 1900 que fue redescubierto pero
incluso cuando fue redescubierto por
primera vez alrededor del año 1900 la
gente no sabía cuál era la base
molecular para estos factores
hereditarios de los que mándela hablaba
y en 1902 tenemos una primera muy buena
teoría acerca de lo que podría ser la
base molecular de estos factores
hereditarios esto es cuando volver y
sharon crean la teoría y lo hicieron de
forma independiente pero ambos llegaron
a la misma teoría más
al mismo tiempo ellos crearon la teoría
cromosómica que ahora se conoce como la
teoría cromosómica de solán y burberry
su trabajo se basa en la observación de
cómo se dividen las células
especialmente la meiosis y en ver cómo
los cromosomas parecen estar en pares
para después separarse para ser
transmitidos a sus descendientes y ellos
dijeron bueno estos cromosomas a un
nivel físico a un nivel molecular
parecen comportarse de manera muy
similar a los factores hereditarios de
los que mendel hablaba así que ésta era
una teoría muy fuerte y luego en 1911
esta teoría consigue más evidencia a su
favor
tomás con morgan de quien ya hemos
hablado utilizó moscas de la fruta para
ver como un rasgo mutante podía ser
transmitido de una generación a otra y
la única explicación plausible que se le
ocurre es que estaba siendo transmitido
en el cromosoma sexual x
y él y su equipo continuaron trabajando
más y más para establecer que los
cromosomas de hecho parecen ser la base
la ubicación física de estos factores
hereditarios de los que mental habló por
primera vez en 1865 y por lo general
cuando pensamos en los cromosomas
pensamos que están compuestos de adn y
eso es cierto pero también se componen
de otras cosas incluyendo proteínas y en
los primeros días cuando la gente decía
bueno parece que los cromosomas son
realmente la base o el lugar donde se
ubican estos factores hereditarios donde
se encuentran estos genes pero cuando
veían estas dos moléculas diferentes
decían probablemente las proteínas son
los responsables de codificar la
información hereditaria en ese entonces
se sabía que las proteínas eran estas
moléculas complejas que en cierto modo
podían codificar información y se
pensaba que él
era este tipo de moléculas aburridas que
seguramente no podían codificar
información y así la primera evidencia
fuerte de que el adn es en realidad
donde la información genética es
codificada no sucede sino hasta varias
décadas después y comenzamos a ver esto
con wi-fi por aquí famoso por el
experimento de griffith donde hace algo
realmente interesante y por sí mismos
sus experimentos que lleva a cabo y
publica en 1928 no son responsables del
establecimiento del adn como la molécula
base de la herencia pero son el inicio
de un interesante camino de
investigación en el que estos señores en
finalmente establecen que el adn es
donde estos factores hereditarios están
codificados
entonces cuál fue el experimento de
griffith bueno él estaba estudiando unas
bacterias específicas y tenía dos
variantes de estas bacterias dos cepas
distintas de estas bacterias tenía la
cepa rugosa y la cepa lisa el observado
que si la inyectaba la cepa rugosa a un
ratón el ratón vivía y si le inyectaba
la cepa liza a un ratón el ratón moría y
esto se debía a que la cepa liza tenía
un revestimiento protector que hacía más
difícil para el sistema inmune del ratón
atacar a las bacterias así que por sí
solo esto es muy interesante esta es la
cepa virulenta ésta es la que va a matar
a los ratones ahora bien él tomó esta
cepa liza la cepa virulenta y la calentó
de manera que las bacterias murieran y
la inyectó a los ratones así que esta es
la cepa liza inactivada por calor y si
ésta era inyectada a un ratón el ratón
vivía ya que esas bacterias estaban
muertas pero
hizo algo muy muy muy interesante tomo
un poco de la cepal y sahin activada por
calor y también tomó un poco de la cepa
rugosa y las combinó ahora en sentido
común nos diría que si tenemos esta cepa
azul que no va a matar al ratón y esta
cepa lisa inactivada por calor que
tampoco va a matar al ratón y las
combinamos entonces no debería matar al
ratón pero resulta que esta combinación
si mató al ratón lo cual era fascinante
y así fue que se le ocurrió esta teoría
del principio de transformación a pesar
de que él mató a esta cepa liza debe
haber existido algún tipo de material
algún tipo de molécula que haya sido
transferida de las bacterias muertas a
las bacterias vivas que esencialmente
transformó a las bacterias vivas en la
cepa liza lo que les permitió matar al
ratón por lo que se le ocurrió esta idea
de algún tipo de principio de
transformación y pasó algún tiempo más
de 10 años casi dos décadas en realidad
y héiber vi mcleod y mccarthy dijeron
bueno que es este principio de
transformación porque no usamos el
experimento de griffith y en lugar de
limitarnos a tomar toda la cepal y sahin
activada por calor vamos a tratar de
dividirla en sus componentes y vamos a
tratar de aislar los diferentes
componentes y seguir haciendo el
experimento hasta que tengamos una
molécula aislada o un componente aislado
que parezca ser el responsable de que
esto ocurra por lo que estaban tratando
de aislar el principio de transformación
y lo hicieron justo como lo he descrito
tomaron la cepal y sahin activada por
calor y separaron los diferentes
componentes de esta que pueden ser
separados físicamente se podría utilizar
algunos detergentes para remover ciertos
componentes se podría utilizar enzimas
que destruirían ciertos componentes y
este es un trabajo muy meticuloso por lo
que te puedes imaginar que toman a la
cepa liza y la activada por calor y
comienzan a separarla en sus diferentes
componentes
así que este podría ser uno de los
este es otro componente
y aquí tenemos otro componente y están
usando diferentes técnicas químicas para
separar todos los constituyentes que se
encontraban en la cepal y sahin activada
por calor original y a continuación en
lugar de llevar a cabo esta última fase
del experimento de griffith con la cepal
y sahin activada por calor completa y la
cepa rugosa lo hicieron con la cepa
rugosa mezclada con cada uno de estos
componentes por separado y luego seguían
realizando el experimento y decían mira
cuando usamos este componente de aquí y
ejecutamos el experimento el ratón aún
vive
y el ratón vive
así que este no transformó a la cepa
rugosa y tal vez este tampoco transformó
a la cepa rugosa pero luego fueron
capaces de aislar algo que si transformó
a la cepa rugosa y el ratón muere y así
este componente si transformó a la cepa
rugosa en la cepa liza por lo que
tomaron este componente y le empezaron a
aplicar todo tipo de pruebas ellos
observaron los componentes moleculares
del mismo y cuando observaron las
proporciones de nitrógeno y fósforo
dijeron esto parece tener proporciones
que son consistentes con las del adn que
es una molécula que ya conocían y no
eran proporciones que fueran compatibles
con las de las proteínas se realizaron
pruebas químicas y observaron que no
parecía que hubiera una gran cantidad de
proteínas en el componente que habían
aislado o incluso de rn que es otra
molécula que ya conocían utilizaron
enzimas que degradan proteínas y
y no degradaron este componente pero la
enzima que degrada el adn sirve grado
este componente y de esta manera fueron
capaces de llegar a la idea de que el
adn era el principio de transformación y
esto es algo muy muy muy importante
piensa en esta búsqueda que duró poco
menos de unos 100 años comenzamos con
los factores hereditarios sin saber
dónde están ubicados por acá dicen
parece que están en los cromosomas
empezamos a tener pruebas de que están
en los cromosomas pero los cromosomas se
componen de adn y proteínas y no fue
sino hasta el comienzo de los
experimentos de griffith y luego mary
mcleod y mccarthy vienen y dicen vamos a
identificar qué es exactamente lo que
hay en la cepal y sahin activada por
calor cual es el componente en ella que
realmente transforma a la otra cepa y
era él
y lo que era fascinante es que cuando se
mezcló el adn de la cepal y sahin
activada por calor con el adn de la cepa
rugosa el adn de la cepa lisa era capaz
de mezclarse con el adn de la cepa
rugosa permitiéndole a la cepa rugosa
producir estos códigos de proteínas
provenientes de la cepa liza que le
permitieron ser más virulenta de manera
que el sistema inmune del ratón tampoco
podía atacar a la cepa rugosa así que es
realmente fascinante en muchos niveles
el punto clave de todo esto es como
hemos llegado a saber que el adn es la
parte importante de los cromosomas al
menos en términos de la codificación de
la información genética pero también nos
lleva a pensar en lo mágico podríamos
decir que es el adn que si mezclamos el
adn de una cepa con otra cepa viva
podríamos llegar a transformar esa cepa
viva en cierto modo ellos estaban
haciendo ingeniería genética básica